welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and mortal kombat delivered the
violent delights and can't be fan
service i expected as a past
too young player of this game
who like luke hang in this movie i
really only knew how to sweep the leg
while my big brother used the famous
combo of real life shoulder punch
still kind of hurts so i'm going to
break down all the cool visual details
and references to the games hidden
throughout this film
spoilers ahead and here we go we open on
the compound of hanzo asashi
future scorpion in 1617. now playing
hanzo in this movie is the legendary
hiroyuki sonata
famous for many roles but marvel fans
might know him as akihiko in avengers
in-game these opening images focus
very much on the gardening trowel used
by hanzo's wife harumi
this is actually called a kunai a
multi-purpose tool for farming and
masonry but also
one associated with ninjas as it's more
lightweight than
the larger more regulated weapons and
useful for gouging holes and walls for
climbing
this whole functionality is key to hanzo
in his whole bloodline like as he rushes
to be han's men he
drops the water buckets that was a tool
that was critical in the defeat of
sub-zero in the 1995 film if you
remember just to signal to us
a whole different approach to the combat
in this movie as hanzo instead combines
the kunai with rope to construct his
iconic weapon
that rope lives on as a symbolic
lifeline tethering hanzo
to his future descendants with cole
young and his daughter
sharing corded bracelets in the scorpion
colors of yellow and black and later
when cole fights goro
he too uses a tool from a barn drawn
from a bundle of
rope and when cole's akana finally
activates it extends
from his daughter's bracelet all the
ropes are connected
and then of course bihan future sub-zero
played by joe tesleem
another martial arts star known for the
raid and fast and furious 6.
this whole opening attack on the
compound is very similar to the opening
of the animated film mortal kombat
legend scorpion's revenge
and here the action in gore is really
well choreographed first with the blood
of the guards
squirting upward as the sword goes
through his body until it explodes at
the neck right when it hits the jugular
and then later the blood seeping out of
bihan's knuckles as that ice breaks his
skin kind of like wolverine's claws
and then of course the freaking ballet
that hanzo performs with the roped kunai
i love this detail how bihan at first
dodges it but doesn't think to dodge it
when
hanzo retracts it scaring his cheek but
then later in their final fight
sub-zero shows that he has been hundreds
of years thinking about that one mistake
so that when scorpion tries to pull the
same move again
this time he catches it but back in the
past bihan leaves hanzo for dead and his
dragon marking fades from his arm
as the flames claim his body leaving
this outline of ash
similar to the way scorpion will leave
sub-zero at the end of this movie then
lord raiden played by tatunobu asano
long-time actor known by marvel fans as
hogan from thor ragnarok rescues hanzo's
infant child saving this bloodline that
eventually leads to
our hero cole young played by louis tan
he continues to don his ancestral colors
with yellow tape around his fists
black and yellow shorts a black and
yellow gym bag strap
he loses the fight by failing to listen
to his daughter
i because i should have thrown the
uppercut off she actually yells the same
advice to him later when he's fighting
goro
and because he listens this time he's
able to get a solid hit on goro
then into the out world where we meet
zhongsung summoning bihan
now sub-zero to assassinate the
champions of earth realm while bihan is
generally seen in blue
they use darker tones for his costume
here as a nod to bihaan's noob cybot
form
and cole meets jax cole young the man
that took the belt from eddie tobias
uh eddie tobias is a nod to mortal
kombat game creators ed
boon and john tobias jax also tells him
could have won today
how'd you control the cage strategically
this is what coal applies
to the final battle using raiden's
ability to teleport them anywhere to
control their own
turf also you could see it as a nod to
the final scene where cole heads to
hollywood to
find the cage jax asks about cole's
marking here
where'd you get it from he was born with
it what do you mean
it's a birthmark notice that this
dialogue was reversed from its order
back in the trailer when it sounded like
jax didn't understand the concept of a
birthmark
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it yeah solid fix there
so sub-zero attacks cole and his family
and jax lets them escape while he faces
sub-zero and in the background in the
graffiti i love this
it reads down right plus lp as in
downright low punch
that's how you do sub-zero's freeze
attack in the game and this is the same
move that sub-zero does on jax
and as he freezes jax's arms you can
actually see blood bursting from each of
his wrist joints and then his elbow
joints
showing how bone by bone his arms are
breaking under the ice before both are
ripped off at the shoulder
back in the outworld melina shows up
reporting to shangsung
molina let's finish this yeah he loves
telling people to finish
of course a nod to his line finish him
in the game and he decides to send the
reptilian
scizoth using the name versions of
reptile from the game call themselves
sonya blade has a classic movie crazy
research wall which is now pretty beyond
trope can we stop putting these in
movies hollywood
anyway it documents the history of gods
and warriors
most of it is real world history stuff
but it does have parallels with
characters from the mortal kombat games
like there's this image of the aztec
sun god which you can see is a nod to
kotal khan the former outworld emperor
based on
mayan and aztec mythology there's an
article about a matuka warrior
a nod to night wolf who you'll know from
annihilation in the other games
there's a vaz with a centaur that you
could see as a nod to motaro in the
games there's also this image showing a
cracked skull that maybe could be a nod
to the visual of when the x-ray vision
shows the attacks as the bones break
but we meet this movie's comic relief
kano who ends up being the one to defeat
reptile
kinda wins yeah this heart rip and the
line of course directly out of the game
and then kano spits on this gnome
marking it for sonia later when she uses
it to stab him through the eye
as kano leads them to raven's temple he
struggles to work his gps it's actually
pretty similar to the way in the 95 film
that sonia's compass doesn't really work
due to that
island's mysterious magnetism but
they're found by liu kang who leads them
into the temple past these murals
depicting past
champions including the great kung lao
ancestor did this movie's kung lao
the hood adelia with her husband argus
goro ripping a dude in half
and outworld emperor shao khan and when
cole sees the painting of the fight
between hanzo and bihan he experiences
another vision
yeah you can barely make out scorpion's
voice through the fire saying
unleash me as the wrappings coat the
blade handle
foreshadowing the visual of cole's armor
it's interesting that he's speaking
english here right i'm thinking when
these warriors become these kind of
demonic figures
perhaps their language changes from
their native japanese or mandarin
to the english that cole hears it as
which might also explain the
get over here kano tries to steal the
amulet of shinnok
this is one of the most powerful items
in the mortal kombat universe used by
shanak when he
and the other elder gods waged war
against the one being
it enhances the wielder's powers
drastically
which might give kano a way he could be
resurrected in a future film since i
don't think we actually saw him put it
back
after luke kang told him to also nearby
is this blue fan
probably the steel fan of kitana who was
also a no show in this film but will
probably appear in the next one hey you
know i'm someone who's got a lot of
things going on at the same time i'm a
bit of a multi-tasker and so is my
toothbrush
and thanks to the elements sonic
toothbrush from vanity planet for
sponsoring this video
it's got a uv sanitation chamber that
kills 99.9
of bacteria that's in addition to the 40
000 brush strokes per minute it can hit
which is about 39
000 more brush strokes that i can manage
on my own so the element sonic has four
brushing modes
clean soft whitening and massaging it's
also got a two-minute auto timer that
ensures you are brushing the ada
recommended amount of time
while a 30-second interval timer prompts
you to move to a different area of your
mouth are you sitting
out i'm feeling it i'm good now
here oh
god it's got all these features and it
looks cool it actually comes in multiple
different color ways so that you can
match it to your bathroom if you want
for a discount of
78 off that's huge just click the link
in the video description
discount code new rockstars vp will be
automatically applied at checkout if you
use our link brush shows teeth sub zero
attacks liu kang but kung
lao saves him using his signature hat
throw
and then he pops up from under it with
his ground teleport move
and then shang tsung says but there's so
some mice
which is what he always says after he
sucks out someone's soul as he does to
kung lao later
here in the fighting pit kung lao tells
cole all you can do now is test your
might
yes test your might it's the name of the
minigame for the mortal kombat series
also a line in the awesome 1995 mortal
kombat techno syndrome track
liu kang spars with kano sweeping the
leg
real cute let's see you drop down again
that the only move you know
yeah yeah sweeping the leg the classic
maddening [ __ ] move that i
totally would do all the time against my
older brother because i really sucked at
this game
also i wasn't very athletic i really
wasn't good at anything
i'm still not really good at anything
except pointing [ __ ] out in movies
hey but props to kano for that vertical
jump there which is really the other
move i would just do on repeat when i
didn't know what else to do
liu kang tells cole about his old master
beauright show
a character from the games master of the
drunken fist and a playable character in
mortal kombat deadly alliance deception
armageddon and mortal kombat 10. at
dinner time kano's rage
activates his arcana his eye laser
ability
notice afterwards how kung lao is
smiling a little bit revealing that this
insulting kano was all part of his plan
to invoke kano's arcana
we made other out world champions
including the hunter netara
general reiko cabal and of course goro
now cabal is voiced by
damon harriman who played charles manson
in both tarantino's once upon a time in
hollywood
and mine hunter on netflix so natara
doesn't last long kung lao uses another
move from the games turning this hat
sideways into this buzzsaw splitting her
in half flawless victory
yes flawless victory what you hear when
one fighter beats the other without
taking any hits which kugalan actually
does here if you watch it closely he
dodges natara's strike and then grabs
her to steer her directly into the saw
meanwhile goro attacks cole and his
family and it is
emotional pain being the pain that cole
needs to inspire his arcana as a
descendant of hanzo who lost his family
and you can see that flash briefly in
cole's eyes as goro is slamming the
truck there
and now with his arcana activated each
of goro's pounds to his armor results in
less and less recoil on coal
charging up his armor so that he can
deliver the uppercut that his daughter
wants
and then finishes off goro by cutting
off the sand slash his chest stabbing
through the eye meanwhile jack sargana
gets activated by lifting the boulder
off sonia
fills out his rebuilt arms into the
thick super strong ones we know and love
and as kung lao's soul gets sucked out
cole pulls liu kang through the raiden
lightning bolt portal into the void
i just love how each bolt forms what
kind of looks like the fold of a curtain
that drapes in front of them
just a really cool design choice to show
how they're like folding in space
to get out of there so cole suggests
that they split up and confront each
champion in a different location
including the pit stage the recurring
stage from the games this is where jax
faces raco
as their fight ends reiko kind of gets
that faded neck roll that fighters
always do in the game to set up a
fatality and jax's fatality is of course
his skull clap move that's also a big
one from the games sonia fights kano
back in the production cost saving
location of her home
the dagger gets flung loose going
directly into the target board
drawing of sonia holding kano's severed
head maybe this is her
response drawing to his graphic novel
art that he's always doing
meanwhile against cabal liu kang
performs his famous bicycle kick from
the games
knocks him into the muck where he
finishes him with his classic fire
dragon move
fatality
and sonia now with kano's marking blasts
a hole through melina's body leaving her
spine intact but
also somehow the flesh on our side of
the spine is clearly blasted away
like the blast curved around the spine a
little bit and the ribs are torched away
but not the meaty tissue around the
spine uh
whatever it looks cool and melina's
body's just freaky sub zero takes cole's
family
and they fight in this frozen fighting
gym and as cole's hand
bleeds on hanzo's kunai it awakens his
ancestor
get over here
yep you heard that the instrumentation
there just shifted to
the 1995 theme song
yes i did a lot of yellow belt karate
demos to this and again great fight
choreography here
scorpion sword gets wedged in the ice
and then later he stabs sub-zero with
the chain blade and drags him into that
sword so that he can use the same chain
to pick back up the sword and then
sub-zero cut scorpion releasing
blood and freezing it into a blood
sickle dagger and then stomping an ice
wall
into existence just to throw scorpion
into something
and then when hanzo sees cole's frozen
family we intercut with shots of his
wife and his son
also frozen past and present combining
as hanzo realizes that his future
bloodline is at stake here so working
together with his descendant scorpion
finishes off sub-zero with his famous
fatality from the games moving his mask
to breathe fire from his skull mouth
and hansa's face actually fully reverts
to that skull as he returns to the fires
of hell where if you listen closely
there's a voice summoning him there
ah yes we are likely hearing the voice
of quan chi a sorcerer from the nether
realm who keeps scorpion's soul in hell
another person we might meet in the next
film and then in the final scene you all
caught this one
cole said he is headed to hollywood in
search of a new champion for their team
passing a poster for
action movie star johnny cage starring
in citizen cage which is a title that he
has brought up in some of the games
i love his cage belt buckle it expresses
a larger than life ego
making me think they might cast a pro
wrestler in the role actually ed boon
said that he supported casting wrestler
the miz as johnny cage in the next film
actually speaking of the ego maniacal
apparel
this shirt is actually one of our many
great merch options that you can support
this channel directly
by purchasing at newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
oh my shoulder still hurts
[Music]
you